los hospitales afganos están al borde
del colapso bajo el régimen del grupo
talibán sumado a las históricas
carencias de equipamiento y medicamentos
la salida masiva del personal sanitario
y la reclusión de las profesionales
sanitarias en sus hogares después de la
toma de afganistán por los talibanes
pone en jaque la salud de millones de
afganos así lo alertó la organización
mundial de la salud tras su visita en
terreno han les orienta actions tech a
menos que se tomen medidas urgentes
afganistán se enfrenta a una catástrofe
humanitaria inminente los trabajadores
sanitarios se están marchando creando
una fuga de cerebros que tendrá
consecuencias durante años
ucam la oms se mantendrá durante tres
meses del financiamiento para la
continuidad de los servicios sanitarios
esenciales pero con el retorno de los
talibanes al poder se congelaron los
insumos de ayuda humanitaria
internacional la financiación extranjera
dado que la comunidad internacional no
reconoce al nuevo gobierno talibán las
consecuencias son patentes en los
hospitales
y estamos utilizando nuestras reservas y
casi se han acabado pedimos a la
comunidad internacional que reanude su
apoyo al sector sanitario oh dios no lo
quiera si no recibimos su apoyo nos
enfrentaremos a una enorme crisis
lawrence talbot si el colapso sanitario
se refleja también en el rápido aumento
de los casos de sarampión el
resurgimiento de la polio o la
malnutrición infantil uno de los grupos
más vulnerables y la crisis de seguridad
hizo que la pandemia pasar a un segundo
plano pese a que los casos han aumentado
en los últimos días la gente está
preocupada todo el mundo tiene una
especie de estrés mental ya que el
gobierno ha cambiado ahora solo intenta
ganar dinero para comprar comida porque
el costo de la vida ha subido nadie se
preocupa por el virus
mientras tanto los líderes talibanes
apelan a un diálogo con los países
extranjeros en pro del pueblo afgano